JEN: Today, we're talking
about Cloud Domains, Network
Connectivity Center, and
reCaptcha Enterprise.
I'm Jen, and welcome
to This Week in Cloud
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We created cloud domains
with the goal of simplifying
domain-related tasks.
And we've continued to build
on that initial release
with new functionality.
Cloud domains
allows you to manage
access controls for
domains through Cloud IAM
and manage your domain
registrations and renewals
through cloud billing for
a more seamless experience
with the rest of Google Cloud.
Head to the blog for more
functionality and to get
started.
Network Connectivity
Center-- our unified network
connectivity
management solution is
generally available in 15
regions across the US, UK,
India, Australia, and Japan.
And we are en route to
expanding this coverage
to include all
Google Cloud regions,
enabling global on
ramp to the Cloud.
We are committed to maintaining
an open and flexible cloud
networking environment that
will enable interconnectivity
with the Google Cloud
network, and partners
play a critical role in this.
Check out the blog for details.
ReCAPTCHA is a security
product and has always
sought to be hard on
bots and easy on humans.
As bots have gotten
smarter, we needed
to adjust to keep this balance.
So in this latest version
of reCAPTCHA, reCAPTCHA
Enterprise, we've created
a new detection method
that provides a frictionless
experience for users,
but is still effective
at identifying bots.
To learn more about our
two primary principles,
protect users and provide a
frictionless user experience,
check out the blog.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.